what's the most interesting fact about
meerkats probably not their interest in
sunsets like this one in the Kalahari
Desert in southern Africa lots of
animals even humans would love a sunset
like this it might be the markings under
their eyes did you know those dark
markings act like sunglasses allowing
the meerkats to see in the harsh desert
light here's another interesting fact
since meerkats are perfect snack size
for predators like eagles and jackals
one meerkat and sometimes more always
stand guard for the mob a mob of
meerkats that's actually the name used
by natural ists
is a meerkat social group from five to
thirty members here the mob gathers to
observe the deadly puff adder by the way
meerkats are fiercely territorial and
will fight to defend their turf from
snakes or other meerkat mobs speaking of
territorial once they've staked out a
territory they use their four-digit
claws to dig burrows and tunnels where
they'll sleep after a hard day of
hunting
meerkats grow to a length of 12 inches
weigh about two pounds and are members
of the Mongoose family they like to
wrestle this habit begins at an early
age interesting but the most interesting
fact about near cats is what they love
to eat these cute little critters love
to eat scorpions they're immune to the
venom first the meerkat bites off the
stinger
good move and then it's time to tie on
the feed bag if scorpions aren't
available meerkats will also dine on
anything they can overpower beetles
spiders even lizards and small rodents
but for a meerkat nothing beats the
crunchy goodness of a freshly killed
scorpion and who can argue although well
a little ketchup might help